joining us now is someone who has spent
a lot of his life
in or around the us military retired
lieutenant colonel oliver north he's the
author of veterans lament
is this the america our heroes fought
for he joins us tonight
colonel thanks so much for coming on you
you're good you gotta wonder i i thought
of you this morning
and of people like you some of them
relatives of mine
what you must think watching the
leadership in some cases civilian
leadership but also the uniform
leadership
at the pentagon turned so starkly
political
what effect is that going to have well
you know what they're they're trying to
send you
a message it's time you woke up
in the full meaning of that in our
modern jargon uh the the reality of it
is that they're outraged
you for playing the president's comments
at the pentagon
that statement about flight suits and
hairdos and things like that and i'm not
trying to denigrate him i'm just saying
that statement was made after he made
his first visit to the pentagon
talking about the most important thing
our military does and you summed it up a
moment ago
our military has two missions no more
than that number one
deter war and number two if you have to
fight a war
win it okay they're outraged that
you basically allow the president to
step on it
and you you replayed what other people
had not just totally ignored
look it it's even worse and you summed
it up secretary of defense austin
in congressional hearings has said one
of his primary missions
and i'm quoting now stamp out sexual
assaults
rid the ranks of racists and extremists
what does that mean
that means that someone is going to have
to find out who they are
he also said you cannot defend america
keep america safe is the way
i think he put it from our enemies if we
have enemies
lying within our own ranks now i served
over overall 25 years 22 as a us marine
officer
okay i was wearing a uniform for a
quarter of a century i never saw
when when i came in the marine corps i
believe that the actual
expression was in those days you had to
sign a document under pain of perjury
and one of the questions on it was are
you now or have you ever been
a member of the communist party and then
they added on
nazi party and then they've added on a
whole bunch of others it's called
standard form 86 for a security
clearance
and it's it's now volumes what used to
be four total pages
i interviewed for that book you just put
up i interviewed
my colleague and i dave gaddison dave
catch and i
interviewed 500 veterans okay here's one
of the most important things about our
military
our military has in it tens of thousands
of what we call
legacy volunteers it's an all-volunteer
force we don't draft anybody
oh i'll give you an example my dad was a
world war ii hero he's the first hero i
ever knew
i've kept my i've kept company with
heroes most of my life
my brothers and i all served in uniform
why not because dad said we had to
dad said you want to and and that's why
we all served
all of us in combat my brothers and i
now i look at those kinds of things and
say to myself
and we've we've asked gone back and
asked this question now
the expression i've got your back is one
you see played out in the movies alright
i'm covering your six
i've got your back are four very
important words they're not a sentiment
they're a pledge
that pledge goes up and it goes down it
goes to the guy standing beside you is
carrying a real ar weapon
not not ones that they voted in the in
the house of representatives today about
the bottom line of it is that loyalty
pledge goes all the way to the top does
this
president have the backs of those guys
who volunteered to come in the service
i don't think i don't think so this is
this witch hunt that's now underway
1.5 million mandates lost from readiness
and preparing to deal with the number
one adversary that we've got on the
planet earth
the communist chinese and xi jinping
yeah
it's all it's all you put it so clearly
and i think it's clear to everyone who's
paying attention except to the people in
charge which is which is terrifying
colonel north i appreciate you coming on
tonight it's great to see you
thank you semper fi buddy